-Our first guest tonight is
a Tony and Emmy winning actor,
you know from "Boardwalk
Empire" and "Westworld,"
as well as the "James Bond"
and "Hunger Games" franchises.
He just received his first
Academy Award nomination
for Best Actor
in "American Fiction,"
which is in theaters now.
Let's take a look.
-Here you go.
-All right.
Yeah. Wait a minute.
Why -- Why are these books here?
-I'm not sure.
I would imagine that
this author, Ellison, is black.
-That's me. Ellison.
Yeah. He is me.
And he and I are black.
-Oh, bingo.
-No. Bingo, Ned.
These books have nothing to do
with African American studies.
They're just literature.
The -- The blackest thing
about this one is the ink.
-Please welcome back
to the show,
our friend Jeffrey Wright,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-Thank you.
-Oscar Academy Award nominee.
-Yeah.
That happened.
-That happened.
-Yeah.
-I feel like
this is a real
compliment to you.
And I don't know
if you've noticed it,
but I think when this happened,
a lot of people
were saying things like,
"Oh, I can't believe
it hasn't happened before."
Now, of course,
you were well aware
that it never happened before,
but it must have been nice
that you'd done work
over your career,
that people were surprised
in the moment to be like,
"Oh, I just assumed Jeffrey
would have had one by now."
-Yeah, I suppose
that that's true.
And what's wonderful
about this, too,
is that it's acknowledgment
from our peers that,
you know, "Job well done,
we appreciate your work."
So I've had the opportunity over
the course of the last weeks
to run into people,
actors that I admire
who said, you know,
"I really like your work."
And it's been a lot,
but it's been really touching.
-That's really nice.
-It's been really cool, yeah.
I'm grateful.
-What were your expectations
on the morning
when the nominations came out,
and how were you receiving
that information?
-Well, I didn't watch
the announcement ceremony.
I didn't want any sudden
unforeseen damage to screens.
You know, in case the news
was not to my liking.
You know,
I wanted to save those --
save those repair costs.
-Yeah.
-So I just kind of
wandered around my house
was in my office a bit.
I had the phone
on a coffee table there,
and I just waited
and it started to light up
and it seemed like good news.
So, yeah,
but I ignored the thing.
And then I looked up
and I saw a picture of my mom.
My mom passed a few years ago,
just about a year or so
before I got the script,
and we had a moment
and that was nice.
-That's wonderful.
-First person I talked to.
-And you had -- Your daughter
was in the house?
-My daughter was not
in the house.
-Okay.
-So my daughter had been on
leave from school for Christmas.
So it was her last night
in New York,
so she decided to go to one
of her best friend's houses
the night, uh --
the night before.
And, you know, she was up late,
so she was asleep.
And then she came home,
and I'm doing interviews,
you know,
doing the Zoom interviews.
People want to know, you know,
your reaction and all that.
And she's downstairs,
and I hear her like,
you know, having breakfast.
I'm like, "Hey, uh, what?
You're gonna come up?"
And she's like,
you know, "I'm having eggs.
As soon as I finish
these eggs, I'll be up."
You know, I'm like,
"Well, come on up."
You know, she eventually
comes up and, uh -- and I said,
"You know why I'm doing
these interviews, yeah?"
And she freaked out.
She realized.
-Oh, that's good.
So she finally came to it?
Yeah.
-Yeah, she finally came around.
-She was the last one to know.
-Yeah, she was.
-And then you mentioned
she was home from school.
You then had to spend the day
of your nomination news,
you drove her back to college.
-That was my celebration. Yeah.
-[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
Let's hop in the car
and drive up to New England.
Yeah.
-Just a chauffeur.
-But she --
I mean, that's, you know,
my family, like my -- my --
I had the good fortune
of being raised by two women.
My mother
and her eldest sister,
my aunt Naomi,
who after my mom passed,
came to live with us
for a couple of years.
And then I was able to
build a house down in Virginia
where they're from.
-Oh, wonderful.
-So she's moved back down there.
She's 94 years old.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Her brain is sharper
than mine, believe me.
Which is not saying much,
but, um,
so she -- I don't hear from her.
I call her up, I say, uh --
because she has
trouble seeing now,
eyes are faded a bit, so she has
difficulty dialing the phone,
but I call her up
and I say, uh,
"Hey, uh, Nay, did you hear
any news this morning?"
She goes, uh, "Yeah, yeah,
I heard that.
Yeah, yeah."
-[ Laughter ]
-"Yeah, that's great.
But you should have been
nominated years ago."
-There you go.
-So, you know.
-There you go,
you got to honor the vote here.
-Yeah.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-But that that, you know,
that's family, you know,
that's my family.
"You should have
done it years ago,"
and, you know,
between that and, uh, "Sorry,
I'm eating my eggs,"
you know?
-I just like that your whole
morning with, uh,
after you got nominated
was walking around
to family members being like,
"So, did you hear anything?"
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And when my aunt,
I'm not sure of what she said
was like an indictment of me
or of the system.
-Yeah, exactly.
-System's wrong, man.
-Right. That's the way I saw it.
But it'd be funnier
if she's like,
"Why have you been doing
work like this earlier?"
-There's dual meaning there.
There is definitely.
-I want to talk about the work,
I want to talk
about the great film.
We'll be right back with more
from Jeffrey Wright after this.